tourisme quelle a été la destination
préférée des français pour cette année
2006 on pense à l'espagne ou encore
l'italie bien c'est le maroc qui arrive
en tête une ville profite
particulièrement de cet engouement il
s'agit de tanger là-bas l'authenticité
est encore préservée mais les
infrastructures sont en plein essor et
les hôtels se multiplient reportage
aurélia glee main et didier da il y a
quelques mois encore l'hôtel tomber en
décrépitude
aujourd'hui c'est l'un des
établissements les plus prisés de 100 g
après des travaux accomplis en un temps
record le reef hotel mythique du temps
j'ai des années cinquante a rouvert ses
portes un symbole dans une ville qu'on
disait sans avenir touristique
voilà c'est une suite seniors si le
phalanx et la chambre et la magnifique
us sur mer vue sur mer et sur chantier
car c'est toute la ville qui est en
travaux
centre d'affaires résidence de vacances
hôtels de luxe les projets de complexes
en tous genres fleuriste à vue d'oeil
les promoteurs s'arrachent des terrains
vagues qui ne vont pas le rester
longtemps
ça sera un hôtel cinq étoiles de ce côté
là puis un hôtel 4 étoiles un centre
commercial de 30 mille mètres carrés des
espaces bureaux et une tour d'habitation
de 25 étages tanger est à nouveau
séduire et pas seulement les touristes
d'affaires dans la médina que rist
aurique de la ville des efforts de
réhabilitation ont aussi été entrepris
et commencent à porter leurs fruits
il ya énormément de personnes qui
achètent qui achètent autant pour en
faire des maisons d'hôtes que des
maisons d'art ou tout simplement pour un
usage privé
un nouveau visage pour attirer le plus
grand nombre mais qui inquiète les
amateurs d'authenticité qui est temps de
vous dire parce que je pense que pendant
une dizaine d'années ça ressemblera
peut-être à d'autres villes de la côte
méditerranéenne qui ont été presque
entièrement reconstruite cette année
tanger enregistre 15 % de fréquentation
plus une progression qui concerne
l'ensemble du pays et ce n'est pas fini
partout des ouvriers sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour augmenter la capacité
d'accueil
là on ne fait que répondre à un
potentiel que le maroc à qui et 3500
kilomètres de côtes et c'est pour ça que
nous allons offrir aux touristes
six nouvelles stations balnéaires 5 sur
l'océan atlantique et une sur la côte
méditerranéenne
le maroc qui s'est remise sans séquelles
des attentats de casablanca mise plus
que jamais sur son potentiel touristique
avec une ambition qui n'est pour
l'instant qu'un slogan 10 millions de
touristes en 2010